Zero-emission aircraft is really about Airbus having the ambition...
...to bring an aircraft which can fly with no impact on the climate to reality by 2035.
We see it as a moral obligation that we need to bring climate-neutral flying to society.
So what we're talking about here is really powering aviation with renewable energy.
We're going to be developing the technology, testing that technology on ground.
And what we're also going to start seeing are flight demonstrators,...
...which means we're going to take that technology,...
...put it into an aircraft and fly it, test it to its limits...
...and really understand the performance.
This challenge is not only about an airplane,...
...it's about having the right fuse hydrogen at the right time,...
...at the right place, in the right quantity, at the right price.
And there were people who said, "No, that's not going to happen.
What are you saying?"
Of course, it will happen.
I believe that this is the most exciting change...
...that the aviation industry has ever seen.
So let's leverage now the energy and the enthusiasm...
...and derive concrete actions to meet those ambitious targets together.